[Music]
in uncomfortable interview news Oh word
submitted by to be a good boy to be a
good boy
it's an old song that we made 2008 God
we got to show you man there's a lot of
gold we made a lot of gold you don't
wish to shoot a lot of sketch come can't
peel copy us
damn did they know yes Annelle did
though they called the ultra v-neck and
then they came out afterwards with the
older v-neck sketch yeah and ours was
better yep hella people copy our [ __ ]
[ __ ] Colin yeah you guys should sue
them and go out of business from fees
and trying to sue them yeah Jimmy
Kimmel's being criticized for his
behavior during an interview with stormy
Daniels aka a porn star who had a stormy
day a porn star yeah that's bad uh well
yeah the reason why she's in the news
right now is because it came out that
she allegedly had a sexual relationship
with Donald Trump back in 2006 and so
now media is just like why was I
surprised because they're saying that
she was given she was given hush money
oh but in she said I'm not gonna be her
son thirty thousand dollars a month per
month and other reports are just saying
that's the totals all night regardless
that's a lot of man to shut the [ __ ] up
she was getting this money before the
presidential election in 2016 but this
is all from that book right fire and
fury um
no so this is like there's been multiple
times that this has come up in the media
I don't even know why people act
surprised though I already imagine
billionaires are always banging in porn
stars all the oh they better be man can
we see what stormy Daniels looks like
yeah well is she really stormy here so
this is storming Daniels with Donald
Trump around that time
we had this alleged affair yeah we will
always look too old yeah and in that
kind of a look all gonna hear actually
Oh videos now we had sex yeah stormy do
you like it stormy he had been married
to Milania for a year and in 220 and
2006 she had just given birth to the Sun
so got Sun yet his band he's been with
her for a minute though Milania yeah
no I mean um jump in Melania
yeah yeah yeah I saw them on Zoolander
yeah they were I thought and recently
too
so anyways this is what she looks like
so Jimmy Kimmel had her on his show and
he did like a about 12 minute interview
and I'm gonna show you three minutes of
that interview were you seeing all these
like comments to a point where he got a
lot of backlash on the internet for it a
lot of people were like what the hell
this is like like what the [ __ ] is this
some kind of comedy thing like and then
they're just he better not be action or
sex questions you don't ask a porn star
sex no you can't work for sex questions
hope he's not doing no comedy bill was
about sex question you gotta ask them
math math questions that's right science
question she's a woman fratty what is
salacious that sounds sexy yeah that
sounds really good you can either have
your steak medium rare or salacious it's
heavy or conveying undue or
inappropriate interest in sexual matters
are you talking about film actress no so
that's kind of weird I really don't
appreciate that boy yeah and then people
are just saying that he this is like the
Kimmel from back in the day when he used
to be on the mansion show oh girl oh so
it's not it's not weird behavior then
well now like his brandy is not new
no but I'm just like how the [ __ ] are
you surprised anyway okay so here's the
here's the clip we even got her on the
original statement does not yeah just so
you guys know that what he's talking
about here there was these two
statements fading from her supposedly
that she never had sex with Trump and
that they're just denying it but then
he's pointing out the fact that this
signature is different from her regular
signature match the signature on this
statement and I went through my library
of photographs of you to compare it at
for headshots that you have signed and
these seem to match the original did you
sign this letter that was released today
so you're saying perhaps this letter was
written and released without your
approval like to imagine him you don't
have to imagine him I like to imagine
him though like lying in his bed with
cheese burger wrappers he's a god it was
so great at the State of the Union
tonight and then it turns on the TV and
he's like oh no it's for me why are you
on that talk-show when you could be here
in bed with me having the most fantastic
lovemaking of your entire life you can't
say whether you have a non-disclosure
agreement but if you didn't have a
non-disclosure agreement you most
certainly could say I don't have a
nondisclosure agreement yes you're so
smart Jimmy thank you very much you're
at a golf tournament Lake Tahoe
you know this Trump looking you on the
course he approached you in the gift
from him he asked for your number
asked you to have dinner with him you
told him you would meet him in his room
he asked you meet him his room you
assumed you'd be going out to dinner
when you got there he was in pajama
pants he asks you a lot of questions
about the business side of the
adult-film an email and said they gave
you a story in the middle I was like
yeah we would love to have stormy on the
show of course we would love to have her
you said in the interview that you could
describe in detail Donald Trump's junk
do you use that one good god I don't
know what's wrong with it it's
wrong with you it's a question but I got
three carats here there's a prize that
kinda looks like his dick and without
any commentary would you like to pick
the carrot stormy puppet perhaps can
answer some questions
there's the puppet and look who's here
with us does this at all seem familiar
to you
tighty-whities if you have done
something don't move
shake your head no okay never have I
ever had sex with a married man at a
golf tournament never have I ever
watched Shark Week in a hotel room with
the host of a reality show she's not
moving
one last thing did you have you ever
made love to anyone whose name rhymes
with llama well you whatever you want me
to claim well it was the way though it
was edited it's probably harder to to
get comfortable yes yeah but I mean I
watched personally i watch the whole
thing and I'm like well there you have
it folks the leader of the feminist
party herself says that it's totally
fine there you go I'm well according to
the to the fans because everyone thinks
you're a feminazi have you noticed it
have you noticed that every that
everyone nowadays like after the sexual
revolution we've had right now everyone
wants to like roll back to this
puritanical thing where you don't talk
about sex stuff yeah like you like right
it's like oh don't ask a woman about her
underwear or or don't ask a guy boxers
or briefs or like this is all you guys
can ask me all you want right I've done
this is like back to buckle shoes back
to [ __ ] you know I mean like back to
the Petersons times when [ __ ] the
religious law was law of the land and
like everyone couldn't talk a certain
way and say bad words and interview
someone like
and tox-ex like what's wrong with
talking [ __ ] sex I had somebody blow
me up a couple years ago
her name is Brizzy voices she's a
[ __ ] YouTube person right and she and
she was like cuz she cuz she was trying
to bust me because I was talking about
like sexual things with people on the
street she's like oh you put these women
in uncomfortable situations and I'm like
look anyone can just [ __ ] walk away
from me anytime they ask if you want you
want to talk to me about [ __ ] or
whatever and and we're talking about
sexual things like what why are you why
is it wrong to talk about sex like in
your head like what who taught you this
who taught you that it's that it's like
taboo or not cool like if anything I'm
what is what is the uncomfortable
situation because you do realize that in
order for them to be on the video added
to be a but they was with their consent
is if I use this for YouTube yes ma'am
did it seem rapey to the ladies here
what it did what Jimmy Kimmel's no I
mean it just felt like he's being a
comedian and he clearly has this like
hate for drama and I think he was just
trying to make this situation that's
like in the limelight right now he's
just trying to make it light-hearted and
the bit isn't about her is about Trump
Trump and not making fun of her yeah
exactly because you know if anything
yeah he went into this interview knowing
that she can't say anything like he/she
can't confirm anything at all that's why
throughout the whole interview she just
keeps dodging the and what people don't
know is this stuff is planned she knows
they give they give her clever things to
say they gave her a joke I then was the
same night that Trump was was address it
was during the State of the Union
address so it's relevant do you think
like when they have [ __ ]
was it what's the what's the [ __ ]
laughing clown what's his name dolls oh
that the the talk show guy that lasted
everything Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Fallon so
a Jimmy Fallon does his little [ __ ]
bit with you know where the artist has
to make a voice impression or something
you don't think they know that ahead of
time like oh my god how did he do that
on the spot I like it when Slavoj the
celebrities do impressions of others
love Bertie
I think what people might be upset about
is this is slightly outside of Jimmy
Kimmel's branding for him to kind of
drill the talkshow I mean the the guests
that hard and maybe that's just what
they feel uncomfortable about is it yeah
he usually does it it uh doesn't usually
talk about sex all the time
so I think to talk about sex in the
drilling like that much I think that's
outside of its branding he's always like
interviewing like very neutral like
Jamie Foxx tell me about your movie and
it's very like that yeah I mean cuz he
has been vocal about just his distaste
distaste with Trump yeah in the past and
that already for me was outside of his
branding because after the man has
opinions now oh no because in the man
show he was just I mean have you seen
the mansion match I've not seen it was
great it was funny yeah yeah was there
was a lot of crew jokes it was just very
like real talk like just man type [ __ ]
you know like like I don't really girls
on trampolines and skirts I see yeah it
was just big enough to where it's a
fourteen so then after that like he
cleaned it up to where he can be more
digestible like in the message be he be
a more power major right now yeah so
then um when he came out with his
distaste for Trump then for me I was
like oh [ __ ] that's kind of edgy again
he was a gangster I think so and then he
did it this time and I think people
probably forgot that first time and
don't know his past we're just like what
the [ __ ]